for as long as there have been
broadcasts there have been people trying
against all odds to steal the spotlight
during them as I said the ambulance just
left a firetruck just left and there's a
firefighter there right now firefighters
say that the you're on private property
luck and today because anyone with a
webcam computer or gaming console is
capable of streaming themselves to
potentially hundreds and thousands of
people at a time everyone can be the
star of their own show but with the
riches glory and adulation Fame can
bring so to comes the risk of drawing
unwanted attention
the threat of becoming a target exposed
in the crosshairs of a stream sniper
[Music]
stream sniping is a term that describes
a unique situation in entertainment when
a viewer of a live stream attempts to
directly insert themselves into the
broadcast in gaming this is usually done
to gain a competitive edge as having
access to a streamer screen provides an
incredible vantage point for the
potential sniper the emergence of stream
sniping coincides with the release of
Starcraft 2 which brought further
attention to the already growing
broadcast medium and it was here that
notorious high profile stream snipers
like Deezer and combat X began to make
names for themselves in the sc2
community stream sniping usually meant
queuing at the same time as the target
while the term stream cheating or
ghosting meant actually using the info
against them unleash it lookey control
he would have placed Pino because he
thinks I'm cheating do they both look it
I know we're you and I'm gonna proxy you
[ __ ] ass
but being able to visually get access to
competitive information predates
streaming in online FPS like
counter-strike ghosting referred to
spectating an enemy player while dead
and giving that information to a friend
to help them gain the upper hand many of
today's games simply prohibit this kind
of behavior you might get some kind of
kill cam but you can't spectate enemies
there are exceptions though like Rainbow
six siege which actually encourages dead
allies to use other sources of
information like cameras to help their
team yes shoot to the wall do it right
and Aeryn but stream sniping and modern
games has become easier and seemingly
more rampant especially with the rise of
the battle royale genre in games like
fortnight where there isn't yet ranked
play the system just forms game lobbies
as players queue up so you enter
matchmaking at the same time as the
streamer with the hope that you'll both
end up on the same flying bus everybody
on good great wonderful however in games
that rely upon a ranked matchmaking
system like hearthstone it's a little
more difficult you have to be close to
your targets of rank on top of timing
your queue with Aires but it does happen
every warrior before you go can you give
me a threaten just so I can prove to
twitch at that you're watching the
stream through two that I'm not crazy
I just need one threaten regardless of
exactly how the Snipe happens it's an
issue that is constantly a topic of
discussion
streamers find it infuriating and for
good reason they play games to entertain
people but their experience can easily
be ruined by snipers well let's just try
to get dog you disrespect let's try to
kill him a minute
here we got no line all right I'm
[ __ ] dead dude I'm [ __ ] dead dude
I'm [ __ ]
big boomer 69 I'm assuming we're getting
extremes time - yeah he's clapping -
this guy's from sniping can someone clip
that please I'll just get this guy
[ __ ] banned but it's these types of
reactions that are oftentimes the end
game for these mischievous marksmen
I see ninja all the time I've gotten him
like eight times like I feel like it's
kinda douchey but like his reaction just
makes me so happy the devious
motivations behind stream sniping can be
far more shallow than simply gaining a
competitive advantage for bragging
rights sometimes it's done exclusively
with the intent to harass
bye-bye i buy me over and while this
trollish behavior will often spoil the
experience of the streamer as a
spectator it's oddly capable of adding
to the entertainment whoa whoa well
there huh what's going on here that was
a quick change of pace huh
I seen you punch your monitor let's go
[Music]
home it's not punching me you weirdo
this is weird
[Music]
hey this guy's punch me I need you to
kill him hey later [ __ ] suck my wiener
I'm pissed it ID I got punched out let's
not talk about it sure
streamers can easily put a delay on
their broadcast to prevent being sniped
but that means less interaction with
chat and less real-time feedback one of
the key things that sets streaming apart
from say TV in order to deal with
sniping without broadcast delay many
games now offer streamer modes that hide
or anonymize relevant details like
usernames for example in league of
legends there are even community made
mini map overlays that block out
everything but the lanes themselves
preventing snipers from gaining key
information about the streamer and some
developers have even tried to protect
the high-profile streamers that play
their game with corrective action this
was the case with shroud and summit 1g
who are allegedly being poached
while playing player unknowns
battlegrounds [ __ ] everywhere the
suspected snipers received Swift bans
despite denying the charges and it
caused an absolute uproar within the
community in a response pub G
corporation said stream sniping is
against their Terms of Service and that
no one gets special treatment you it's a
tricky problem on one hand the streamer
is choosing to broadcast their position
to others but some argued that banning
players for using that information is
just special treatment for instance a
player that shouted out their build
order to their opponent and Starcraft
would not be similarly protected on the
other hand if the most popular streamer
of a given game becomes frustrated that
becomes the developers problem and that
was the case with Tim the tap man and
overwatch I don't want to stream the
game where because I literally get
strange sniped every day
by a Symetra one trick and I try to hide
my screams but they're still they can
still have a chance to get in I don't
want to play that it's not fun but until
they can figure out what they're gonna
do with like an offensive Symetra or one
tree I'm not interested really following
Tim's disavowal of the game
Blizzard investigated the stream sniper
in question and announced that the
heinous individual had been banned for
systematically ruining overwatch games
for thousands of players but stream
sniping isn't exclusively a problem for
gaming in fact it has been responsible
for some crazy and dangerous moments
during IRL broadcasts as well yeah
what's that what you doing yeah what are
you doing so yo what the [ __ ] you doing
what the [ __ ] bro instead of showing up
in your Lobby and trying to ruin your
game people are physically showing up at
your actual location and trying to ruin
your life surprise [ __ ] what's
certain is that as streaming continues
to grow in popularity the issue of
sniping probably won't go away anytime
soon
developers can only do so much and at
the end of the day a streamer is
choosing to stream whether you think a
broadcaster can or should be protected
from this behavior or should be treated
the same as everyone else
sniping isn't going anywhere man I just
think it's so sad that people are so
desperate for attention that they steal
a spotlight from other people it's just
hey guys column for the score eSports
here do not forget to tune in to top 10
this week when we cover the top 10
Cinderella stories in all of these
boards really dude
best oz top 10 that's not enough for you
I was gonna warn you I was gonna warn
you but then I was like he [ __ ]
deserves it you last night I'm gonna
sneeze again so watching I warned you
you could have taken us well having
fired a 50 Cal in my life I can tell you
that it was
[Music]
[Applause]